es sind dokumente die einem das herz in
die hose rutschen lassen anleitungen in
denen es schritt für schritt ganz genau
erklärt wird wie baue ich eine bombe in
niedersachsen haben jetzt waldarbeiter
einen unterirdischen raf bunker gefunden
der diese bomben anleitung und
chemikalien vermutlich aus den 80er
jahren jetzt ans tageslicht gebracht hat
der vater anfang der 80er jahre ihr
wohnungswesen geändert zuvor gab es
konspirative wohnung wo die
raf-mitglieder wohnten und auch ihre
ganzen utensilien also waffen
sprengstoff geld ausweise usw gebunkert
hatten
und da hatte man umgeschwenkt und hat
praktisch den hausrat in den wäldern in
diesen depots vergraben es gab insgesamt
18 derartiger depots und da war alles
drin was halt raf denn sie war pistolen
maschinenpistolen auch das gewehr mit
dem die begleiter von hanns martin
schleyer erschossen worden waren
und es war gelungen nachdem man ein
depot gefunden hat das zentraldepot in
heusenstamm bei frankfurt da lagen wir
über 100 ausweise darin nicht nur über
55.000 mark d mark sondern es lagen
entlang auch drinnen berge von
beschreibungen zu anderen depots und die
wurden von dem bundeskriminalamt
entschlüsselt man stellte fest insgesamt
17 andere depots noch und es ist
gelungen von diesen 17 depots 11 zu
entschlüsseln
und bislang haben noch sechs gefehlt und
möglicherweise sind es jetzt nur noch
fünf die bisher noch nicht entschlüsselt
worden sind und was wurde jetzt genau in
niedersachsen wie sie es nennen
entschlüsselt wir haben ja bereits
gesagt dass wurden chemikalien gefunden
aber auch ihm eine anleitung wie man
eine bombe baut in niedersachsen
überhaupt nichts entschlüsselt die
sprach eben davon dass 1982 in dem
zentraldepot dem sogenannten in
heusenstamm bei frankfurt gefunden
worden waren eine reihe von utensilien
und darunter waren auch beschreibung zu
anderen depots das war zu sagen die
liste mit hinweisen auf alle anderen
depots und diese beschreibung die waren
verschlüsselt und das bundeskriminalamt
hat und der einsatz von zwei des
experten diese unterlagen entschlüsseln
und hat so festgestellt dass es
insgesamt
10 depot es gibt dort hingefahren hat
sich das angeschaut und wie gesagt sechs
konnten bisher nicht entdeckt werden die
anderen elf wurden entdeckt und
abgeräumt und wir haben es eben in dem
beitrag gehört dort wurden dann auch top
terroristen verhaftet und christian klar
war eben die rede und fünf tage zuvor
waren die raf köpfe brigitte mohnhaupt
und adelheid schulz verhaftet worden
das war praktisch im november 1982 das
ende der zweiten raf-generation und
jetzt hast du in niedersachsen was wurde
da genau gefunden was wissen sie dazu
der laufenden augenblick ja noch die
auswertung unterlagen ist wurden
gefunden eine reihe von dokumenten
interessant ist an der geschichte dass
die bilder die jetzt bekannt bekannt
geworden sind dass die vor dem behältnis
ja übereinstimmen mit anderen fotos
anderen depots das waren diese behälter
in die auch wasser eingefüllt werden
konnten hier oben verschraubt werden
konnten und beispielsweise gab es genau
dieses depot auch in der das war der raf
deckname in der in dem depot neue
fünf-zimmer-wohnung das in der nähe von
heidelberg im november 1982 entdeckt
wurde und ein praktisch identisches
verhältnis hat man damals gefunden also
es deutet einiges darauf hin dass es
sich um eines der gesuchten depots
handeln könnte es deutet einiges darauf
hin letzte klar denke ich werde die
ermittlungen im landeskriminalamt
niedersachsen ergeben und gibt es denn
ähnlichkeiten zu den bisher gefundenen
depots ja also ähnlich ist dass die
praktisch die gesamten utensilien wie
führen aufgezählt dort versteckt worden
sind und das wurde noch unterschiedlich
aufgeteilt also in meinem depot waren
mehr ausweise in dem anderen geht hoch
war der sprengstoff in einem anderen
depot waren mehr waffen je nachdem und
hier ist es halt anleitungen zum bau von
sprengstoff und bin auch gespannt was
bei der analyse der flüssigkeiten
herauskommt also ob das flüssigkeiten
sind aus den mann sprechen materialien
fertigen kann also parallelen ja ich
habe es eben schon beschrieben die
äußere verpackung identisch und die
ganze art des werberinges des weg
schafft es das passt alles in das bild
also einer von möglicherweise 8
drei bis möglicherweise 18 depots und
hätte auch tapete das meine letzte frage
ist sind ja noch immer raf ex
terroristen die nicht gefunden wurde wie
darf man sich da jetzt die ermittlungen
vorstellen wie wie geht das da jetzt
weiter nach so vielen jahren auch für
die ermittlungen zuständig ist das
landeskriminalamt in niedersachsen hat
es ja eine vielzahl von banküberfällen
gegeben die diesem trio zugeschrieben
werden ich betone zugeschrieben werden
und da muss man jetzt abwarten aber ich
denke dass das das depot von nicht viel
aufklärung geben kann denn die sie die
post wurde angelegt anfang der 80er
jahre 1982 war das ende der zweiten raf
generation und die drei die jetzt
gesucht werden die wären ja alle dritten
raf generation zu gerechnet also es ist
die sache relativ unwahrscheinlich
erstens dass die mit den depots was zu
tun haben aufgrund der zeitlichen
abfolge und es sind ja mehrerer raf
mitglieder wie eben geschildert an
depots gefasst wurden also die
sicherheitsbehörden sind jedenfalls über
viele jahre davon ausgegangen dass die
raf-mitglieder oder neue mitglieder sich
diesen depots nur mit größter vorsicht
oder am besten gar nicht anhören wollen
denn doch einmal hatten die ermittler
erfolg das war damals die größte
gezielte förderung in der
polizeigeschichte deutschlands über
2.000 beamte observierten dieser
insgesamt elf depots die aktion hieß
eichhörnchen und 2000 beamte mussten bei
wind und wetter zittern und bewahren und
hat sich aber gelohnt ist wurden die
drei köpfe der zweiten raf-generation
gefasst mehr nachrichten und breaking
news nur bei bate schaue ich hier das
nächste video an und vergiss nicht zu
abonnieren